what a week indeed Rogers versus Brady
mahomes keeps going off and me and
simcha hears Mayfield's whoa and we're
here to talk about how we wish you lived
on the west coast just because then
Sunday Night Football will be done at
eight o'clock ah I mean can you imagine
that like getting done with the football
day and then going that let's watch
let's not your movie honey or I know for
some reason when the Sunday Night
Football is over and I look over my
girlfriend's fallen asleep on the couch
and I feel like I've accomplished
something I'm like watched every snap
did my job like I feel like I did
something when really I just sat there
and went god does why I just do
everything by himself yeah I know
meanwhile meanwhile speaking of Sunday
Night Football
hello you come on television ooh Oh
Aaron Rodgers number of questions yes
people on Twitter we're going I can't
believe he did this this is nuts
did you tell anyone advance that you
were gonna do that hi Doug I did say it
while we were watching the game I was
like I'm singing tonight help you know
I'm singing and then what do they say Oh
Chris he really does say a lot yes yes
they did they just kind of laughed of it
and this is something I would tell to
everybody out there right in my life too
yeah if you're always the crazy class
clown guy yeah people kind of go they
let you slide with stuff like yeah I
don't know if they were totally happy
with me because you know it's like I'm
still new to that show yeah and not
everybody understands me or anything yet
so I think that's where they're like you
know learn to gain their trust first
then you can start to break that and so
what they said kinda yeah the funniest
thing about doing television is the
dozens of people that will never be on
camera that stand around so it's people
doing the cameras people doing the
lights oh you started going all Aaron
Rodgers did you feel like a lot of newly
gained eyes like a look up at you yeah
that crew there and they know me enough
the camera guys and I've seen him even
through the years when I was at CBS and
some of them were carryover so they they
know you know and me and my loud
comments at times and making things that
are you know not always politically
correct and things like that they laugh
whatever one note for everybody out
there the [ __ ] the play
up we're getting a bunch set right now
that any other funny random football
stuff any long-form stuff sometimes you
guys will DM us like seven like long
dm's in a row use Sims and Lefko at
gmail.com fend jerk has been kind of
going through that and just using as a
place for you guys to communicate with
us
we even a guy send his paper about why
Baker Mayfield is different than Johnny
Manziel and apparently our clip with
Sean McVeigh made German television ooh
so it's like what I'm saying with German
subtitles
I've always pictured you as a German ooh
you sexy role player yeah now that is
sexy but there's something hot right now
is there there's something steamy so hot
there's something magical are you
talking about Nick thank you
there is a spirit growing inside of this
very room can you feel it right now
I don't you should week six four and one
week seven five and Oh week eight five
and Oh week nine five and Oh Chris Sims
this is on a heater in Waco Chris Sims
you are 15 and oh the last three weeks
and guaranteed to lose thank you
you are 19 and one in the last four ooh
wish I've been parlaying myself dumb
idiot and I have something from you for
now on
I don't know if you're ready is it under
there is it the t-shirt to harness the
power you are the true Oracle now you
have earned the right to your own
crystal ball use it how you feel fit
what do you see what do you see Oracle
Paige is gonna win the Super Bowl again
dan wait for real that and there it is
everybody man the crystal ball thank you
very much
yeah Josh got it my GT yells and uh damn
I guess some of my bets have been pretty
good lately too
let's just say that people have been
money lining your bets and making
hundreds of dollars on you damn so the
one thing that you should listen to in
our betting show that comes out on
Friday all the way at the end might as
well listen to the whole show guaranteed
to lose five teams that simms guarantees
we'll lose them for the last three weeks
you've been perfect Ben I'm fire that
was a ballsy one picking Packers and
newing but not really not real you know
people that's what I mean you gotta get
over the quarterback thing you're a
hundred percent the last three you're
95% the last four I am and your bets
have been great too
I've been pretty good what did I did I
push my lead up a little bit
never your picks a bit absurd thank you
yeah heavy right it is heavy I feel like
I got a pretty good feel for the NFL
right now nothing you never really have
a total field
it's a crazy league and ball and it
bounces a lot like way but like Saints
Rams which we'll get to in a little bit
when you argued with me boy were you
correct and I'd like to apologize to
Sean Payton I blacked out apparently I
said Sean Payton's gonna look across the
sideline and go Oh Sean McQuade you're
the better coach I was wrong and I am
sorry I didn't mean that
[Music]
seriously Sean Payton was looking across
the other side of like you think you're
stealing my [ __ ] alright but the one
thing I want to do is I want to get back
to basics okay and I think at the Sims
Lefko podcast a lot of things have been
happening in the NFL universe that we
have talked about for a long time so
let's go back to amendment 1 Aaron
Rodgers is the greatest quarterback
we've ever seen your text on Sunday
night yeah we're pure sadness well I I
was I go through mixed emotions watching
that game I've went through three three
to four years of actually hoping they'd
lose games like that so we can move on
from Mike McCarthy and maybe Aaron could
get a offensive mind like a Josh
McDaniels or a Sean Payton or McVeigh or
shin ayin whoever one of those type of
guys but at the same time man I just
love when they're playin and especially
when they get into the playoffs and
watching him in big moments I mean he's
the most fun player to watch in football
for me so yes and I could see the
storylines happening before the game was
over and that's when I started to text
you cuz I started texting you story
lines you're like no one is saying this
yeah you were saying that Brady
outdueled Rodgers like that's what you
thought people were going to say and I
was like no one could write that and
then you log on to espn.com this morning
and the first thing is Brady out duals
Rodgers and what you said is the Packers
did things the Patriots would never do
right they would never have that Aaron
Jones fumble during a critical Drive
what you're trying to take the lead they
would never rough the punter and do
something dumb like that right you know
have I mean have somebody kicked out of
the football game call a timeout in the
third quarter on first and ten when
you're on your own five-yard line oh my
gosh if you got a delay a game who would
have been first in 12 and a half I mean
the two and a half yards is worth the
timeout
that's just dumb [ __ ] I don't know what
else to say like you know England
doesn't do that crap and then I
furthered along my anger with you to go
you know why is it that New England is
the team that plays on these type of
games and acts like they're the
underdogs like they haven't been to the
Super Bowl
18 years straight right there are the
ones that call the flea-flicker in the
first
they're the ones that call the Edelman
pass back to James way and there's you
know I mean they don't have the ego to
go all ourselves good enough they they
try to give themselves an advantage at
all times I thought about that last
night when you texted it I thought you
know the teams that really unleash the
wagon right now and I don't even know
that's a real phrase no I think it is
Andy Reid yeah well dial up a trick play
Sean Payton will dial up a train at
least like yesterday
Sean McVeigh has shown that he's willing
to take chances but I don't even think
his a lot of his trick plays come on
specialty yes exactly right that's where
he does it you're right because I would
almost say that his offense is
complicated enough where Ron Rivera will
dial up a good fake yeah it's almost
like Mike Tomlin I feel like will allow
his team to do some crazy stuff it's
like once you have the clout then you
can be a little bit more creative when
really it should be the younger coaches
that are trying to make their way that
are should be willing to take the risk
exactly right it's the team like I
watched Vance Joseph and I go can I get
a risk
all right ever take a chance to
something come up with something you
know and and and and it's not about
coming up with something the week you're
playing this is where the greatness of
these guys is right with the Sean Payton
or McDaniels or a McVeigh even though he
does it with the special teams like you
said which is totally correct there's a
lot to fossils credit it is their
special teams coordinator and he's done
it forever forever but it's not like
they go into the game that week and
they're like this is the week we're
calling it they always practice that
he's part of their place it's part of
them every week where they go and go hey
let's run that trick play and they run
it if they run it twice a week before
they finally call it in a game they
think is the right situation well the
thing that I loved about both trick
plays James White totally sold and ran
for like a few steps and I've never seen
it where it kind of goes sideways like
it was an actual running play it wasn't
a draw and the other thing about the
Edelman white one was for white and
those four or five offensive linemen to
completely act like the play was dead
the amount of practice that it must take
to really refine that human mechanism
yes but also I've never seen that many
offensive linemen out on a screen before
yeah
I've only seen two maybe three never
seen four or five no I mean is that was
a really interesting way to do it and
the fact of like what you're saying the
discipline not to cross the line of
scrimmage because I would be forward I I
was sitting on my couch going Oh legal
men downfield that's that's Belichick
he's unbelievable he does it's that's
why you know when we sit there and watch
him do amazing pick plays on Monday
Night Football or somebody go I was a
pic play yeah but he does it within one
yard of the line of scrimmage where it's
legal he he does these things and gives
him steam an advantage but does it all
within the rules and that's what's
amazing about him and them and just
everything they do if somebody was gonna
come to you in the office and go Brady
beat Rodgers yeah what would you say to
them I would go oh oh he beat them
that's right it was just those two it's
nobody else in the field it's the
ultimate it's my biggest problem with
the whole quarterback situation right
now and people think I'm being a hater
on Brady when it comes to this no I'm
not being a hater I'm just being a hater
on you know the storyline the national
media lines that are saying this
happened because of this no there is so
many things that happen during that
football game and to give one guy the
credit to me is just ridiculous at times
I mean it really is
I mean Brady Brady did not play real
good last night I mean that's the real
thing I mean Brady went through a
stretch where they could have put the
game away and he couldn't hit a thrower
yes I think even Al Michaels was like
that's the longest stretch is in
completion at a time right in his whole
career so those things right there you
know and again Brady was still awesome
it's not it's not about that I'm just
fighting the the national storyline and
trying to give people the real what's
really going on and yes he's amazing and
I'm not trying to take anything away
from that
but damn the Patriots honor another
level from the Green Bay Packers and
what they do I mean what they do on the
defensive side of the ball let alone
what they do on the offensive side of
the ball the vision to go hey we get
this Cordell Patterson oh we could play
him a tailback and still run them saying
that since the off season because he's
built like latavius Murray he just
tricks everybody cuz he's wearing any
form we go well he can't really do that
he's played receiver he's been a ball
carrier his whole life I watched the
kids since Tennessee my brother went
College with him at the Tennessee
Volunteers I know what kind of freak
athlete he is and what kind of person he
looks like in person yeah and you know
those are the things again they have the
vision and the the guts to go who cares
he's played receiver his whole life he
can return kicks he returns Ponce he
breaks tackles I've seen it all before
what's the difference between and giving
them a toss sweep and doing that and
they might even have Sonia Michelle or
Gronk I know I mean but were you serious
oh the Patriots gonna win another Super
Bowl if you had to bet your money on one
Tino in the so I would be if you made
you bet Saints Chargers Chiefs Rams
Patriots if I had a bet like if I like
if I took your house and I put it on the
market right now right how dare you and
you only have one team to pick who would
you put it on I think I'd put it on the
Rams yeah I know I thought you were
gonna say Center Patriots yeah why on
the Rams I mean we'll get to those notes
in a minute but the Rams are good well
yeah we know that I the Rams are I still
think the Rams of the most talented team
in football well and I think that
yesterday yes they lost that game but I
really think that's gonna be they're
gonna look back at that when the season
is over and go man good thing we got to
go down there and play in that
environment and get a taste of that that
was real playoff football show that we
can get punched in the mouth and come
back teen straight in a dome loud noise
okay they're gonna have to play their
dome in the Super Bowl now they might
have to go back there again and play in
the playoffs to play against the Saints
now that if they've all stands you know
status quo as is or I think there's a
lot to be taken away from that game
growth I really do
I don't know how you bet against the
Patriot I it's really hard I know the
one thing that I loved about watching
there there are four teams that played
yesterday and I'm not gonna put the
Chargers in there because their Chargers
offense doesn't give me this feeling
yeah when I watch the Patriots the Rams
the Saints and the Chiefs every time
they touch the ball I go this is gonna
be special and their offense takes
everything like I'm watching the Chiefs
game in its third and 20 and they're
Spencer we're on a fake screen to the
right screen to the left gets a third
and 20 and I go
they can do anything I'm watching the
Rams a much and Malcom Brown tightrope
and go-go that's the backup running back
I know I'm watching the Saints and I go
I mean every time camara touches the
ball I go what do you do with that like
what are you doing now and then the
Patriots are they could be the fastest
offense the NFL they could be a slow
moving offense but all of them whatever
I think is gonna happen when the play
starts they can all completely change in
an instant and I'm completely wrong and
I go this defense has no chance yeah
even if it's an amazing defense I know I
know I feel the same way it's a great
play design good talent execution
thinking outside the box with plays
constant pressure with personnel
formations the different ways in which
they can beat you I think that's what
all four of them have and I think you're
spot on with that Aaron Rodgers is out
there with a beaten up an older Randall
Cobb and two receivers who have six
names and I don't know how to correctly
pronounce any of them right Marquez
Valdes scantling and a quantum a saint
bruh equina Mia st. Browne and we're
sitting there ago and I mean I've seen
this Valdez scantling kid catch a
touchdown before well that's what drives
me crazy going back to our original
point Cris Collinsworth this guy's
really putting on as rightie was the one
playing with no Pires how does he do
this that's what I mean everyone still
goes back to Brady with that rashik
called well-seasoned Jabar Gaffney and
they talked about that like it was I
know I loosened that again it sounds
like I'm a Tom Brady hater when I'm
trying to say these things but I mean
hey Ben Watson still contributing to
them
Gronkowski greatest Titan ever Moss
greatest receiver ever other than Jerry
Rice okay Deion Branch I mean damn you
only want a Super Bowl MVP and then went
to another team and went to the Super
Bowl is the number one target for that
team too but he wasn't good Wes Welker
the greatest and first slot receiver in
the history of the NFL really I mean New
England invented oh we can make a whole
offense around the slot receiver Wes
Welker then to Julian Edelman again I'm
not trying to hate on Tom Brady I really
want everybody to know that know the
true thing is is that but I'm afraid
that tom brady's pub
saying it now I know it's more of the
the bloviator x' and the fan I just want
yes and I and I was second again to say
Tom Brady's physical ability is
underrated he has one of the best arms
in the history of the sport is it Brady
as it Rodgers Favre or Dan Marino or LA
no but it's right there off of it it's
that close and that's what I don't think
people get credit for I mean what Brady
doesn't get credit credit for and then
there's his toughness and ability to
execute and make those big throws in big
situations but yes I hate when people
start saying that crap to me because
that's lying that's lazy and that's a BS
comment are the Packers done like are
they are they even capable of making a
playoff run like a lot of years you get
to FiOS you go if the Packers get in
they could really make a run I don't I
don't know if they got it this year I
don't know either
I mean it's Dom's and Wilkerson was so
big in my face it was it really was
because they do have speed and people
that can cover in the backend you know
Kevin King getting hurt early in that
game last night that hurt him you lose
Kevin king in and then Jermaine
Whitehead gets ejected for the slap and
that was stupid and you traded ha
Clinton dicks like who did you have back
yeah well that was an unnecessary one
that him being kicked out no that was
ridiculous was a Fivefinger say the face
I mean you're suspended yeah that's just
and you know again you know yeah just
that I'd totally disagreed with that I
totally disagree with that but overall
it was a it was a good game wasn't a
good game wasn't as great as we expected
it to be no yeah
all right amendment number two yeah Kyle
Shanahan is our favorite coach in the
NFL I've got to do a little self Scout
yeah I'm gonna read you the quotes that
we said about Nick Mullens before the
Thursday Night Football game yeah Sims
Derek Carr is greater than whoever the
[ __ ] starts at quarterback for the San
Francisco 49ers especially the other guy
until he completes the pass I don't
learn isn't it I stand by those comments
what I stand by him at that time I was
right oh yeah yeah you know they admit
now jeez no I said hey Sims I learned
that he's a 6 1 2 tenor which means that
I'm gonna watch the game on Thursday
night going look at this
little [ __ ] running around it's not
gonna be good
number one Nick Mullens played fantastic
for what he was asked to do to go out
there with that poise
I love the storyline that he wears
number four that he went to Southern
Miss that he the same agent as Brett
Favre Brett Favre calls him after the
game and then his speech in the locker
room afterwards I told you guys after
the preseason against Dallas that even
though it's preseason this is the reason
we played this game well guess what now
it's the regular season and this is why
we've been in the game and like I see
Trent Taylor and all those guys yeah
humble brag I was da man with George
Kittel he's like I [ __ ] love this kid
like you could tell the team
legitimately legit okay so number one
what had you heard about this kid from
Kyle if anything other no only thing I
knew from Kyle was the smarts part of it
smarts part of that he was like knew the
offense better than anybody else on
their team other than more than Jimmy G
and more than CJ Beathard
yes Kyle would tell you that Nick knew
the offense better than all that yeah
nick is like a total gym rat as far as
the playbook was concerned and knew
every little detail was the quickest one
to pick it up then couldn't it be argued
that with an offense as elaborate and as
successful as Kyle Shanahan that the guy
that knows that the most will win the
most well you know not always because
then you know you physical tools do come
into it now when the people are that
open like the other night know the
physical ability does not come into it
so I have to ask you
yeah what is the hype train going to
strong for Nick Mullens because right
now I'm here and people talk about he's
an up-and-coming quarterback alright
this is the same thing now here we go
let's let's be realistic okay I mean the
first touchdown passed the PR gar son
fake the run to the left he boots out to
the right there's nobody in the TV
screen for Pierre Garcon there was
nothing now that's great that he threw
the ball to the wide open receiver but I
would like to think that every
quarterback in the history of football
would have hit that throw and that would
be a touchdown alright so what okay
throws then we're gonna good slant on
the second test good slant on the second
I think that was the third touchdown
you know then we go to the not the
George Kittel one the one deep in the
zone oh yeah you're right you're right
you know what it was that was a good
play
yeah okay so that's good read the needle
right okay that you know but then we go
to the
they package and it's oh look at this
screen pass look at this four-foot throw
and then the guy runs for 25 yards yeah
right you know those are the things
again he's doing a nice job but let's
not overdo it don't start telling me
he's out doing what Andrew Luck did the
week before against the Raiders no he's
executing a great offense that has
exposing another defense and he's just
taking advantage of that alone and I'm
not trying to take credit away from but
I just we anoint these guys I got
friends texting me do you think there's
more hidden gems like this in the NFL
well yeah there is if they play for Kyle
or Sean McVeigh yeah you'll find Sean
Payton Yeah right you'll find him though
though
don't hit the wide open receiver you
know you know again the Raiders are a
dumpster fire I mean that has to be
taken into account too but hey yes
there's things to build on I do think
he's a more natural thrower Oh CJ
Beathard I do yes I mean I know enough
after watching that game to go I think
Nick Mullens is better than CJ Beathard
and really if you've watched the Niners
the last few weeks they've only really
lost games because of some CJ Beathard
issues overs right her Nova's hockey
presence stupid interceptions whatever
away bit me but I just that's again not
hating on Nick Mullens I think he can
have a future of the league I'm just
saying let's not overdo it like come on
now come buddy you weren't even
impressed a little bit I was the biggest
I think we overhyped because of the
common fan like me goes yeah here's a
human I've never heard about that goes
into an NFL game on four days and is
able to perform at that level it blows
us away because I've never I didn't even
know this human existed yeah I get it
I guess to an ex player you're not gonna
get amazement out of that you know it'd
be one thing if damn nobody was open and
he was dancing around the pocket and
throwing side arm out routes and
throwing piss missiles down in the
middle of the guys that were covered
then I'd go dim who how did we miss this
guy who the hell is this guy then I
would do that but for now let's just
appreciate what he did and let's
continue to evaluate and not anoint him
king of the NFC West quite yet hmm
that's all I'm saying
you know again I'm not trying to take
anything away but we're just were too
quick to do that this day and age it's
just right away oh he's awesome he's the
best I've ever seen you know Nick fall
should they get rid of course and ones
and just make Nick Falls the franchise
oh yeah let's forget about the four
years he sucked before that and just be
that much of the prisoner at the moment
you know what do you think we should
bench dak Prescott put Tony Romo back in
they're 13 and two they're struggling a
little Oh
let's bench Tony Romo bench don't I mean
let's bench over Tony Romo bench over
Tony Romo hey you're the Rookie of the
Year
I mean it's just it's it's all over the
place that's what drives me crazy as an
ex player and somebody that you know
lives the sport and watches it all the
other thing that it made me think though
was what you've always said about the
NFL these teams are so close to each
other yeah and if you really look at
Vegas and those injuries come out rarely
is there an injury that swings the line
quarterback is usually one of the few
positions where you could be a six point
favorite and then the other guys
quarterbacks out now you're an eight
point favorite but that's like saying
that quarterbacks only worth two points
and you realize it's there's not that
big of a different it's not a huge gap
unless your name's Peterman and then
[ __ ] goes crazy right right
goes crazy right you know yeah you're
exactly right it's it's oh it's we just
that makes had us still too much that's
all we're saying yeah it's just it's
we're putting in amongst your rant 15
minutes ago what is your well we're just
we were everything is quarterback
quarterback the only reason this team
won was because the quarterback at
quarterback and hey again going back to
Tom Brady he's he's missed he's missed
20 games and they're what 15 and 5
without him they weren't 11 and 5 oh and
they went 3 and 1 ok so they're there
they're 14 6 and 6 ok
I mean as great as Tom Brady is great
one of the greatest of all time if not
the greatest of all time there they were
capable of still winning without him you
know as awesome as I think Carson
Wentz's damn it's still a team out there
that supported him and they found the
right formula and they won because it's
a team sport ok I mean the Ravens won
the Super Bowl with Trent Dilfer the the
Broncos won the Super Bowl with Peyton
Manning who was the worst quarterback in
the NFL that year they were
it wasn't close he was the worst
quarterback in the NFL and we too much
are just putting stock into everything
the quarterback does when I watch it oh
what an unbelievable read by the
quarterback you know there's a lot of
plays that go on an NFL football game
where I hear credit and go all what a
read by the the quarterback that's
unbelievable and I'm gonna go man I know
that play you know the 73 scat halfback
choice that Sean Payton just ran or
whatever Brady just ran or even Rodgers
is nobody's above this the coach goes
hey when they're in this coverage we're
gonna run this play just throw to this
guy I just want you to look away for a
moment as you take your five step drop
don't look at him until you get to four
or five and then come to him he'll be
open every time in this coverage and we
make it a big deal like whoa they read
this and he went through his progression
and no it's just you know hey there's
great quarterbacks in long story short
is I'm just saying we're giving a little
too much credit to the quarterback in
the league right now and there's a lot
more to it than that and if you know
gambling you know that Vegas actually
has quarterback tiers hmm we're certain
quarterbacks if they're not playing it
changes the spread by a lot right like
Mitchell true Biscay right now it the
spread will change one or two points
he's on that tear sister there are three
quarterbacks that if they don't play it
changes from six to seven and a half
points can you guess who those three
quarterbacks are before you guess people
at home get your guesses in I'm gonna
say okay good job there on the couch
okay Sims who are you gonna say the
three quarterbacks are that switch
between 6 and 7 1/2 points to the tee if
they don't play um mmm it's only 3 huh
according to CG technology according to
their quarterback values there are
different quarterback values depending
on Rodgers has to be one of Rogers is
one of them man its Brady Brady another
was ok I wasn't totally one other
quarterback Russell Wilson
Russell Wilson hmm nailed it yeah good
for you you know because they can be
proud of you thank you they can do
things outside the norm again that you
know the playbook can't always deliver
oh the Seahawks were down 14 points
yesterday and Russell Wilson took
five minutes on the first drive but they
somehow got the ball back and he's doing
it again and I'm going there was no
other quarterback that could be doing
this right now now Bloods gushing out of
his elbow
I mean he's partially the reason with
the pick-6 they were in that predicament
but I'm gone
that's a great stat I think that's a
Vegas thing but it tells you a lot it
really does in the way Vegas values over
most breezes reason the next tier Matt
Ryan tries a Big Bend right here which
is right right I do have a love co PR
though for the other side of last
Thursday night and that is for John
Garuda yeah I was rereading my book ego
is the enemy because my girlfriend said
that my ego is out of control right now
and I thought okay let me let me dive
back into this and bring me down to size
that's the advantage of having a good
girlfriend who is they're not afraid to
go you need to check yourself got to yes
and I open up one of the chapters and
literally right in front of me I had
highlighted it from the last time I had
read it was the sentence that pretty
much said I'm gonna sum it up that if
you speak about what you're going to
accomplish then it's like scientifically
proven that dopamine is going to fire as
though you've already accomplished it
right think about when you're out there
right now think about how many times
you've gone I'm gonna clean my apartment
this weekend and in your head you sit
back and yeah yeah you're having a snack
and you're going I'm gonna clean up my
apartment I've cleaned up my apartment
this upcoming weekend I'm gonna do my
taxes okay I'm gonna do my taxes but
then you don't actually do it and I
think the problem right now is with Jon
Gruden is everything about him is
promising the future everything about
him is what I'm going to accomplish and
what we're going to do I can almost
guarantee that when Belichick starts the
season he's never talking about all the
wins they're gonna accumulate no he's
not talking about the championships
they're gonna have he's saying we're
gonna take it one day at a time and
we're gonna do it and the problem is is
Gruden knows what the media wants to
hear yeah because he's been in the media
yeah and he knows what the fans want to
hear every coach though knows what the
media and the fans went here yeah any of
them can go up there and go honestly my
players need to step up and I know that
we can win
the Super Bowl if we do what we need to
do coach predict Super Bowl but you
don't do that because you're giving away
part of that energy yeah because if you
keep saying we're gonna build a
championship culture you're not actually
building a championship culture you're
talking about a culture that needs to be
built yes the correct phrases were in
the process of building we're building
right now we hope that one day it can
lead to that but I think Jon Gruden is
speaking in a way right now in which I
don't think Jon thinks he's made a
mistake with anything he's done I think
he has people around him that are
justifying why the khalil Mac trade was
great I think he has people around him
explaining your offense isn't working
but it's not your fault John we don't
have the right guys you should get rid
of Amari Cooper let's get some pieces
there too and even if you think the
value is good even if he's gonna come
out here and say I needed to blow it up
to start over because that's a thing
you're not building right now you're
deconstructing right what I saw on
Thursday night was a team that's no
longer playing for 2018 they are not
gonna be in any game the rest of the
year Derek Carr will have a few games
which the offense kind of makes it click
but when I see you going over to Paul
Gunther with both hands extended going
what the [ __ ] that's when a head coach
has finally because he knows he's got
the camera on him that's when a head
coach knows you're not gonna be around
next year figure it out and I'm looking
at Jon right now and I think he's
wrapped up in this protective bubble and
he it's gotten away from him more than
he ever thought it gets I agree then I
think needs to bring it in and stop
promising things yes we're past
promising just just promise Wednesday
that it's gonna be a good practice and
then go from there I mean Zach that's
what that's what Belichick does that's
what Pete Carril does it's go out there
and compete today today and then after
you compete and are detailed every day
for 90 days in a row then you start to
build something from there and then you
start to go what you're saying
the process has become the culture now
and this is what we do on a daily basis
when I read about Bill Walsh
bill Walsh took time and sat with the
secretaries and taught them how to
answer the phone yeah because he knew
that the culture had to be even that
fine-tuned he went over the stamps they
used on letters what he looked at how
they packed for a trip because he knew
that the coal tried to be changed but if
he went around going
you ready was Super Bowl you ready was
Super Bowl they go well one you were two
in the fourteen legs right but just
think about it I told my girlfriend last
night I'm gonna go to the gym after work
tomorrow yeah she goes paym I'm proud of
you I haven't done anything yet yeah but
in my mind I was like you know what I'm
proud of myself too yeah and I might not
even go to the gym today
yeah cuz I already got the dopamine I'm
betting you don't know I feel really
good right now I think I ate healthy
today I don't need to go to Japan but
that's just something when I read that
chapter and I thought about jungrin I go
me he's promising a lot right now I'm
sending a lot Tina
lost the ear of the team for sure lost a
year yeah and he may have lost all their
trust
yeah I'm I think there's something to
that so you see that though on the
sidelines with curtain in Gunther yeah
well I wouldn't know what Gunther said
back to him he did he popped right back
I want to say he said like something
like you would you run the ball or
that's right it says seems like he said
something like that but I think Gruden
was turned around I heard ed tech yeah
the other thing really quick about
sidelines before we move on every time I
see Tom Brady on the sideline he's got a
coach to his left another guy that was
right with an iPad in his hands every
time I see Rodgers on the sideline he's
by himself
mm-hmm is Rogers just like sitting there
going none of these people can help me
right now they go over there quickly but
mmm again it's just they go over there
he sits on the bench they look at the
drive this plays are simple and they
just sit there and figure out okay what
are we gonna do now what do the plays we
gonna call the next try the wing ones
over they're gone
hey they were all over this and they're
playing this hey Josh I think we should
break out these plays and josh is going
hey when they play this formation right
now it's a it's a quarters and a cover
three game that's what it is
quarters covered three so we're gonna
start going to this and I might package
it with that and bah bah bah bah bah bah
and I
like Aaron sits down they go Aaron what
are you seeing out there exactly Aaron
what do you want it is it's it's a part
of the culture and I know I know people
fight back with me is sometimes they're
like well then why doesn't rob has
change it
Rodgers doesn't know he doesn't he's
never had anybody else change him
they are asking him to do it and all
he's doing is I gotta go out there next
series and do it I got to do it I'm
gonna have to dance around I'm gonna
have to throw instead of throwing 105
miles per hour gonna have to throw one
110 this time I mean that's the way it
is that's the culture of Green Bay
that's what they've had ever since Brett
Favre and he took it over and nothing's
changed on the often your trick point
play yeah your trick play point they're
making earlier right the other thing
that the Patriots do it with trick plays
I think is better than anybody else it's
not just on stoppages so the trick plays
that I see in the NFL are special teams
and there's this moment where everyone's
sitting around they do it or it's like a
team timeout right the Patriots are in
the midst of a hurry up drop ends right
and then hit you with the Edelman to
white throw yeah where you're just
trying to get to the line and you're not
even processing anything and that was
the timing of that play called last
night I go bro he's sitting there and
he's like now but it's not even it's not
even like what should we do should we do
Philly Philly yeah let's do it
no it's more like we're in it and by the
way flea-flicker
and then that right there that you're
doing the quickness right why do you
think they did the quickness just mess
with your brains mess with your brain
but there's another point it's not just
hurry out it's it that that's part of it
but it's still not the main point but
this week there was a main theme of why
they were doing it all the young guys in
the secondary for Green Bay no ha ha is
there you got Jay Alexander Josh Jackson
Jermaine whitehead who's a young player
Blake Martinez who's not that old
they got all these guys Josh Jones has
taken over in the Safeway the trunks
right if he's actually but all these
guys though and that's what I guarantee
they watch that I don't think they can
get this all communicated all the time
let's just do that let's test that let's
see how they do that if that game was in
Lambo would it have been at all
different huh you know it could have
been home-field advantage is a real
thing playing in Lambo I mean I was
like mm no one wins that game no matter
what yes all right so as one is one to
do man the Sunday morning dumps have
been just classic I'll even think if I
was actually talking about that that I'm
who would be the best thing to do
no just the news dumps the shefter
Rapoport dumps that come out Saturday at
like midnight or Sunday morning like
3:45 there just become ridiculous so I
want to go through a few please Josh
McDaniels Ian Rapoport reports that
McDaniels is quote believed to be open
in being a head coach I guess somewhere
other than the Patriots Cleveland but I
thought this already got fixed and what
made me think is so so I have a hard
time believing that the Patriots have
changed their mind on Josh McDaniels
being the successor to Belichick right
but I wonder if like McDaniels and
Belichick were at dinner and they're
eaten and Belichick just go like he's
cutting a steak his medium well steak
and he's like mmm I'll tell you what I
could totally do this for like seven
eight more years and McDaniels is like
what like why why would this come up now
because I think that and I also find
interesting that Rappaport's reporting
well yeah usually knows somebody
connected to the situation yeah but
remember last week with the whole report
that came out about benching Josh Gordon
it didn't happen right Rapoport went
right back for everything I know is Josh
Gordon was late and Rappaport was right
okay let's just start there and
Belichick in my opinion pulled a fast
one on everybody and said ooh I don't
want to sound like we have a leak in our
building so I'm just gonna start him and
then act like this didn't really happen
I really think that's what happened I
love that I kind of know that I haven't
confirmed it but so he's not trying to
flesh out the mole he's just trying to
hide them he says it's it's almost
better to look like there's no leaks
instead of the weakness of Oh things are
getting out of this building and they've
had a few things get out of the building
last year whether it's Gronk's trade
that was Seth Wickersham thing all that
has been you know come out to be
somewhat true what about the phrase
McDaniel's is believed to be open
well I don't think head coach for
another team was ever totally off the
board you know I don't think it was off
I don't think like him and bill like
shook hands and were like okay I'm here
until the day you leave you know bill
was probably very open with like hey
there's something else then you know
tell me it was only because of the Colts
tell me it's because bill and Kraft hate
the Colts because of deflategate and
that's the real reason I don't know that
now it wouldn't shock me if that played
into it I think the biggest thing is
just this that they were gonna lose
their defensive coach who really didn't
play defense in the Super Bowl and they
were gonna lose their offensive coach
who was the only reason they were in the
Super Bowl and they were like damn we're
gonna lose you well you really could see
McDaniels going to a franchise not
called the Patriot well there's I mean I
would have you made me better I'd say no
but I would say this he's an Ohio boy
okay uh-oh so Cleveland and everything
we know is that he like Baker Mayfield
oh okay and damn I mean I know he's 34
but would you turn down a chance of
green baked ham open with Aaron Rodgers
a quarterback this is my question
yeah the Cleveland Browns are super
young mm-hmm
they have a young piece and miles
Garrett they have a young piece in Baker
may feel they have a good offensive line
they have good draft capital they have
good salary cap space
would you take Cleveland or Green Bay if
both offered you and your name was Josh
McDaniels I would take Green Bay I would
I would take Green Bank oh I got four or
five years left of Rodgers I'll find
another quarterback within that time to
take over for him after Green Bay's a
special job Cleveland I don't think the
optics would be great for Josh as soon
as something bad happened they're gonna
go this is what happened in Denver this
is a disaster why did we ever hire him
he was only good at New England
Cosabella Jack Cleveland has shown that
their infrastructure is flawed right
we're a Green Bay is one of the pinnacle
organizations Cleveland you don't have
an owner to deal with in commodity they
may as you mean no Cleveland us they
need a proven commodity head coach like
if John Harbaugh got fired from the
Ravens he'd be great and clean I would
go he could
do that somebody like Bill Cowher all
right
this guy's like dad who have the cash eh
I'm not saying I love it either and he's
been out for a while but the cached for
the base and the team to believe that
they're saying they're done with the
patents the chudd since they can't do
that anymore it's gotta that's that will
not fly for me if they hire them if you
want Josh you'd go to Green Bay I would
yeah that would be amazing
Rogers dick what this is that's how you
get these [ __ ] guys over no this is
what you've been doing like have I ever
told you the story about when we the
Saints came to training camp and New
England has this red zone play they have
to two or three staples in there red
zone that they run that really test your
red zone defenses okay I'm gonna guess
one right one I see I feel like I've
seen Amendola do this a million times
it's like they run to the back and they
either keep going or they just like come
right back going right it's not it's
something along Oh tell me what it is so
they're there first of all their
philosophy New England is high in the
back low in the front right you throw it
high in the back because if nobody gets
out of the way it goes out-of-bounds low
in the front cuz otherwise if it gets
stiff its high and it gets tipped up who
knows he's me intercepted right throw it
low usually just ends up falling on the
ground right well they have this play
where they run it a lot in fact they ran
it last week against Buffalo in the game
and Buffalo was ready for it
but basically it's like a two-by-two
formation right and Gronkowski's to the
right and there's a receiver outside
from the right and then there's two
other receivers to his left for
everybody listening out there tried to
paint a picture Gronkowski's going to
take a delayed release so take his time
let's give it a 1 a 2 a 3 and then start
to run because a lot of the times and
zone and in red zone defense there's
really only two defenses played per se
it's either it's either all-out blitz or
you play somewhat of an umbrella zone
right quarters coverage when you played
Madden which one did you pick did you
pick double a gap blitz or did you pick
one coverage guy I was zone traffic all
the way I'm gonna flood the zone I'll
figure out a way to be a nose tackle and
drop him back to and do all that yeah do
all that kind of stuff but so that's so
they're playing for that so now well
delayed so his delay in quarters would
what happens is the safety who's in
front of that tight end and Gronkowski
he doesn't see him come off the ball and
his rule right then is to go let me look
at the outside receiver and help out my
outside corner because if he runs an in
cut and along the back line like you're
saying up in front who can he can be
there and do that now
the linebacker who's also in quarters
supposed to run out to the flat he kind
of sees the slow delayed release too so
he doesn't fly out there there's nothing
for him to fly out there too and then
all the sudden Gronkowski runs till he
gets one yard in the end zone and he
runs to the pylon and I'm said they are
big he is you're not getting through no
you're not and a lot of times it just
stresses the coverage in general the
where he's wide open your like how
though you watch a game you go what how
does rob Gronkowski get that open yeah
and I was sitting behind and they don't
think they didn't even know I was there
but I'm I'm my practice because Saints
are there scrimmaging against Newton New
England and it's like the second day
third day in a row that Brady's gonna
throw the same touchdown pass and Brees
turns around to Sean Payton right
there's that play again I I don't get it
how does it open every time I don't you
know and that just that shows you those
are the things again Sean Payton and
then installed that play they do it now
but this to show you the things like I'm
saying is you don't know what you don't
know unless you have a coach that's
willing to push the limitations of his
own offense and always steal and find
new plays like like damn my Sean Payton
he comes out last week goes oh I stole
that play from New England Chicago last
week when he ran the little speed sweep
to beat Minnesota right on the right he
stole that from New England he got no no
qualms about it I stole it from New
England suck it and it worked
good use the word thank you yeah I think
it's I think to be a good offensive
coordinator you have to have no ego your
offensive playbook is it's a Wikipedia
it's open for edit anybody can change it
you can add anything at any time exactly
the people that go no this is us are the
people that are often too rigid but you
don't know what you don't know speak of
the Patriots they signed a your guy Oh
mmm Sims was very high on OB melon farm
ooh coming out of
Connecticut got trapped in the second
round by the Raiders yes I was a
non-factor Gruden came in said why are
you not practicing what are you a wimp
and they cut him and now he's being
signed by the Patriots and you know the
rule if the Patriots signed him
everybody else is wrong you were right
gratulations yeah yeah I was right it's
gonna work it's gonna prove me right
he's freakish athletic freakish athlete
Hayes from the New England area news
wrapping exactly right and yes hope from
we'll see if it works out another news
another sunday dump we should do that
but of our Sunday don't dump uh
apparently Jason lockinfo reported that
the Jets tried to trade Teddy for Dante
Fowler in August and the Jaguars said no
hmm I kind of heard that I knew they
made a play for a Fowler I don't know if
I knew that they traded bridgewater
phone but Jacksonville has fallen under
what we talked about oh no we wouldn't
want to win the Superbowl we just don't
want to hurt Blake's feelings oh is that
David Caldwell is that Tom Coughlin is
that Doug Marrone I think that Nathaniel
hacker I'll go with David Calvo but yeah
yeah I just I wonder what they think now
I still keep sitting there going why
doesn't Jacksonville sign Sam Bradford
why what I mean what have you win the
next two weeks right and your
Jacksonville and Bordeaux's plays like
crap but somehow you find ways to win
the game and maybe the Texans drop one
or two exactly you go gosh and he still
keep like I just don't get it I don't
get it what do you think so Diana
Rossini reported that the Giants have no
interest in Sam Bradford but you think I
thought I thought Sam Bradford to the
Giants made sense had success with Pat
Shermer right Oh was what he needs to do
probably knows the offense really well I
can't imagine that Eli's long on the
tooth for the Giants anymore I can't
think so I mean I think the Eli thing is
probably I'm probably coming to an end
soon you think so I do but I don't I've
Letta and his wild goose chase around
the New Jersey Turnpike is probably
change the Giants tune a little bit to
where they're gonna like man I don't
know if we could trust this guy and that
optics don't look good
hey we're benching our 2-time Super Bowl
champ for the old police invader over
here
he's gonna run the offense this week
police evade but yes Sam Brad for the
Jackson now a lot I think they're just
going with Sam Bradford in the Giants
situation they're just going where we're
gonna be in the quarterback market next
year we're gonna draft a quarterback you
don't even want to deal with what it is
and we'll just go from there now a lot
of people would say Sam Bradford man's
made out of glass he look like crap at
Arizona yeah but would you still think
it'd be better for that I think a lot of
quarterbacks would look like crap in
Arizona have you seen that scene that's
a crap team it's crap offense I mean
nobody's gonna look real good in Arizona
yeah you know so I mean Josh Rosen as
good as he's looked has had like five
good drives I mean cuz there's not a lot
of help around him well after our
interview with Jalen Ramsey where he's
definitely supports us and I went back
so this is the thing about the jail in
Ramsey interview we couldn't see him
yeah and then when I went back and watch
the interview I know your wife went amok
scenario he agreed with us it was great
yeah he was really really good he
increased my man crush but Sam Bradford
you would tell Jacksonville right now
bring him in without a doubt bring him
into it out a doubt because if they find
themselves in the thick of things here
and you know bortles has another stretch
that he had where you just go damn I
mean unbelievable I just I don't know
you're just you're wasting time you're
wasting yours I still think Jacksonville
is gonna make a play here I do
I mean they got I know out of there in
their next four games I'm just gonna
double-check myself but I'm pretty sure
I the next four they got Colts twice
Buffalo once and Pittsburgh they can win
three out of those four I know that I'm
right - its Colt Steelers Bill's Colts
so her Steelers it is at home the only
thing that scares me is Steelers this
week play Thursday so they're gonna have
ten days rest but you did only say three
yeah right so I mean you know you win
three out of using one three out of your
next four okay it's the record that
they're gonna be they're gonna be six
and six hey thank you so nine and seven
might get it and I know that my Super
Bowl pick Texans are been looking good
but they're enough both of our oh you're
gonna be screwed with Green Bay yeah
yeah that's what sucked only other
little news nugget Bruce Arians is
formally saying he's interested in the
Cleveland job nothing like a guy a
broadcasting a team's game meeting with
Greg Williams the coach and then
afterwards being like now they lost but
I would totally take that job like I
like you I mean like you sit in a room
with Greg Williams for like 30 minutes
and he's probably there going like I
want to show this team that I can be
their head coach of the future he moved
all this stuff into that office this I'm
the guy and Bruce Arians like now take
that Cleveland has a big shiny star on
top of it everybody wants this Baker
Mayfield and you just nowhere to go but
up and that's it you'll get all of the
credit exactly right you all golden God
but you know what I don't know if I want
to work in that organization I I hear
you I know somebody seems like he's got
to go in the right direction seems like
a loose cannon you know yeah has
Haslam's like the guy that's like you
really want to fire Hugh yeah I know I
mean he used me mr. Jim hi he's 336 and
one you just what are you doing he fired
Mike Lombardi for ray farmer that's all
I gotta say he listened to a homeless
I've already promised Browns fans I
wouldn't do that by the way the Raiders
thing I had a lot of Raiders fans
hitting me up saying stop trashing the
Raiders I'm not I don't think we're
gonna trash the Raiders I don't like to
hit teams when they're down but I do
like to take shots at GM's and coaches
because they're the ones that you the
reason your team is down yeah you know
what I mean right but all right you
ready to get into some film sure Rams
Saints yeah I come to you today and I go
man how great was that film were you
excited to watch it and you go I really
wasn't excited to watch it yeah I was
afraid it was gonna be like a big 12
football game and I turn on the film and
you thought you were like oh man this is
gonna stay yes I did
really quick before we get into that
yeah so apparently the other story was
the Rams tried to get Jadeveon Clowney
earlier this year you do see that no
they tried to get him and it wouldn't
work they also try to get Jerry Hughes
and that didn't work hmm and they
settled on Dante Fowler John Daly
the snaps yesterday something smaller
than I remember him yeah he's you know
he's a true like pass-rush Indiana he's
to 56 to 58 I thought he was in the 270
yeah no he's more a Khalil Mukesh that
he's that kind of guy
yes not even as Jack to sin but Jadeveon
Clowney imagine what's to Davian and
beyond only am I gonna RAM stat - I
don't happen and then my only other
question is before we get into the film
did the Saints win home field advantage
yesterday I'm not ready to give them
that yet they gotta play the Carolina
Panthers two more times they got a few
other games that Atlanta could be an
issue - we saw them went to overtime and
guess what
Atlanta's four and four yet they're
scary I mean once that offense gets
rolling but you know hey they got they
got the bangles they got the Eagles the
week after that they got the Falcons the
Saints the Cowboys then they get the
Bucks and they got the Panther Steelers
Panthers to end the year who have they
played the last few weeks idea of the
schedule pulled up the Ravens Vikings
Rams
so this is the thing is you can't talk
about how the Saints had like seven or
eight weeks in a row they've aced the
first half yes they're three you know
but I would also say the Rams game was a
beautiful game yeah Minnesota ball
bounced their way right Baltimore they
played great but they even got a thing
bouncing their way we'll see I think
you're right okay so where do you want
to start with Rams Saints okay I mean
what side do you want would you rather
no let's start with the the Saints
offense that you've always said that
people accuse you of hating that you
don't hate you actually like one of my
favorite watches in football okay
alright so I think the first thing we
have to start out with is this and this
came out it came to me pretty quickly
and watching the film after about the
first tour drives I said ooh you know
what's different about this game hmm the
Rams d-line is not going to just
outright win this battle you have talked
up the Saints a line for two years now
yeah Andrus peat you were on when nobody
else liked him
Larry Warford the addition and last
offseason - right guard
Terron Armstead is the left tackle that
no one talks Allen talks about a lot of
talk about Trent William
I'll talk about Tyron Smith I'll talk
about Ronnie Stanley I'll just but no
one ever really talks about Turin are no
not cuz he's not quite the big hulking
looking guy he's a little more athletic
bass but phenomenal then they have an
amazing right tackle and rant Brian
ramjet Brian RAM chip and then let's not
forget the Saints probably one that
trade from three years ago yes when they
traded Jimmy Graham for max Unger yes
what happened in the three year since
Jimmy Graham is now on his third team
and Mac and the Seattle offensive line
fell apart and the Saints have had one
of the best offensive lines last year so
you've been all over that yes they own
the Rams D line they did you know didn't
own them but they didn't let the Rams D
line make a mess of the game which is
what they do and a lot of people are the
Rams don't sack the quarterback that
much it doesn't really matter sacks are
overrated
the Rams the line ruins what people are
trying to do they are the kings of the
[ __ ] it up stack that we talked about so
often right so that was the first thing
I looked at I just said men and that was
the reason I really picked the Saints of
the game I just said I don't know if
they can ruin the game first thing we
have to do is talk about Andres Pete I
would I will go out there and elem and
say Andrus peat did as good on Aaron
Donald as I've ever seen anybody at the
guard position anybody and Aaron don't
know how to had a few plays don't get me
wrong the one play we got the backs of
the amara just loaded and Andrus peat
looked at I'm like damn I hit you and
you didn't even break stride and you
just didn't you just ran over my you
know you're never gonna just stop Aaron
Donnell this is Aaron Donald's is one of
the greatest defensive players ever I
just hope everybody knows where are you
gonna say that Andrus peat ranks right
now in terms of guards the Anessa oh I I
mean he's up there he is he's in the
Zack Martin conversation you know
caliche oh oh somali when they're
healthy you know any of the good ones he
never hear his name man no I know and
it's a shame and really his ability was
a big key to the game that could the
fact that they could trust him in some
certain situations ago we think you can
block him man-to-man on third and seven
and drop wild knows it's a wild notion
exactly right so I think that's where
it's got to start but that's where I
first looked at it and just said Wow
okay they got a chance and
then breeze started to drop back and as
the game went on they could not get
pressure on drew brittle he got to Pat
the ball he got it I mean I know there
was no snap sacks but yeah he did and
they don't get me rose a few times where
he moved around and got the bought of
his hand that was a great play but I'm
just talking as a whole the past
protection was a huge part of their
success overall now the other thing is
yeah they threw the ball that's for sure
we know that the Saints did - they ran
whenever they wanted they did run the
ball phenomenal and that's what they can
do and they didn't make a stability of
going up the middle all the time but
they got on the edge between the tight
ends and the tackles a few time with
chimera you know found the right play
every now and then to let sue fly up the
field and then they just replaced them
right through with like a gut where they
call it trap play inside and you know
Ingram rips it up there for 10 yards or
Kimora either way all those things were
good now the thing that I found
fascinating about the game was and this
is people gonna be like what like the
Rams coverage was very good in the
football game that's not really I mean I
know it was phenomenal Brees was amazing
breezes accuracy and pinpoint he threw
some balls where I said who he's gonna
throw that six yard out to Kamara
they're ready for it Lamarque along
where he turned out to court for a
touchdown there was he was wrong like
that right there was two or three where
I was just like ooh that's guts just to
throw it let alone you hit the bull's
eye and got yards after the catch
because you threw it that perfect you
know hey Michael Thomas did good things
mean I need to have extraordinary things
200 plus years 200 plus yards his size
and physicality are unreal but I do want
to collect correct this narrative we're
all gonna look at the 72 yard touchdown
that Michael Thomas had on Marcus Peters
and Marcus Peters I think he was
confused he's talking at the snap I
there's some confusion there but I will
say this as the has a hole for the day
Marcus Peters covered him really well
really he really did Simms he's being a
visceral it's that's a shame and it
there are articles that are saying
that market that the Rams have a Marcus
Peters problem yeah that's just not
right
you know again I will say this what
Marcus Peters was asked to do in that
football game there's only like five or
six corners in football that their
defense would ago we think you can do
that
what kind of stuff Michael Thomas no
matter where he was how he's going in
motion across hey we want you to cover
him firing across in motion and be all
over him like glue he was phenomenal in
the football game but then Michael
Thomas have a few catches on him yeah
Michael Thomas is a giant man but a lot
of those he wasn't open I mean he wasn't
open it was great accuracy and then
Michael Thomas's maybe you know he's in
the conversation for the greatest hands
when he's covered in the sport he's like
DeAndre Hopkins might not separate it
doesn't matter just throw it to him he's
gonna pull it down now Sean Jeffery
right those kind of guys Gronkowski just
doesn't matter at times they're such big
bodies with huge wingspan now he caught
a bunch of slants right and they weren't
all not all these catches were on Marcus
Peters I hope everybody knows that you
know some of these are he's in the slot
and it zone coverage and he's running a
play what we would call like 382 Weis
Nick lookie that's exactly what Drew
Brees is calling in the huddle and he
has a choice as soon as he gets to the
line of scrimmage he goes all during
this coverage of going to Michael Thomas
because Michael Thomas whoever is over
the top of them can go oh I'm gonna run
a slant route of he's head up or outside
of me and if he's inside of me I'm gonna
take two steps like I'm gonna rub the
slam around I'm gonna return outside
it's like an option mount where he's
never gonna be wrong as long as you have
half a brain to execute that so he
caught a lot of those as well but I do
want to make sure that we're not going
crazy on Marcus Peters here
hey yeah could he have made a play here
there a little bit better Marcus Peters
as a whole play good game and was asked
to do things once again that I'm just
telling you not a lot of corners in
football would have been asked to what
he's do that tells you what how highly
he's thought of the the aspect of what
you're saying of looking at the film and
seeing what they're asking him to do
yeah I'm noticing something about the
way we diagnose defensive players in the
public yeah Anthony Barr chasing Todd
Gurley down the side and right they were
eviscerated Anthony
right and the real question is how many
linebackers are really gonna stop Todd
Gurley on a crossing round none Marcus
Peters his face up on Michael Thomas and
we see him get burned and everybody goes
man Marcus Peter stinks
now realize that Marcus Peters has built
a reputation of being a gambler of being
someone that's going to abandon the
philosophy of the defense yes and try
and make a play were you seeing that no
he wasn't messing anything up
other than the long touchdown where he
tried to he tried to jam him and I think
he thinks he's got help over the top he
he missed on that play he missed III do
wanna I don't know maybe if he's playing
the wrong technique all that stuff could
be up for grabs in that certain
situation on that one play the rest of
the game I can tell you that Marcus
Peters played really good football and
gave Michael Thomas Fitz and Michael
Thomas is really good and the Saints
might think they're better I'm just
reminding you
Aqib Talib will be back before the
playoffs exactly right forget exactly
right he's not there right now right
yeah so this is the other thing we have
to take into account in here right don't
get me excited about the ramps okay the
other thing we gotta take into account
is you know they're there they fake the
feel though yep okay they should have
gotten it right
Johnny Eckhart Tolle it's 14 off they go
down to make it 21-14 yeah okay they get
the ball back they go right down the
field again and we're not gonna get into
their offense yeah but they go right
down the field they missed the field
goal they go right down again 28:14
right you know what happens the next
play after that drew Goff throws the
interception right 35 14 right there
three drives game was totally changed
after they miss they blew up so since at
NBC going let go got screwed on this bad
yeah you I mean the game was that game
is a 50/50 game if they play again I
don't even know who I picked that game
is so close and there and the you know
the thing you can't ever take for
granted is the Saints own line braises
ability to understand the total concept
of the game I got an errant Donald here
I'm gonna have to make some throws into
tight windows whether I like it or not
and I got to have a clock in my head to
go I can't let them hit me from behind
and get a sack fumble and totally change
or dictate this whole game right the
thing that was great about that game was
both teams just like Chiefs Patriots
yeah look at their opponent and said
field goals ain't win and [ __ ] right
let's go for the jugular every time
right that was awesome yes it was
awesome um what else am I missing here
uh tomorrow played great Michael Thomas
played great drew Brees played awesome I
don't know what they were doing on the
long play - 72 yards yes see to me this
is where it was all messed up and I
think they were doubling a t'car and
Kemara who was inside of Michael Thomas
so that's where I just go I don't sure
that's where I have a questions about
that whole play in general maybe we'll
find out through the coat the press
conferences this week and all that but
you know that's uh that would that would
be the story of that game in a nutshell
from that's perspect from that side of
the ball all right what about the Rams -
yeah the Rams offense I mean I think the
first thing I have to say is I think
Jared Goff played the best game of his
career Wow yes even with that
interception even without an
interception hey you know he was in a
tough spot when t 814 he was aggressive
I like that I like Jared golf aggressive
Jared golf though yes in that
environment against that team things are
going your way he made a lot of big
throws and gutsy throws where I just
said he's not really open he's gonna
have to throw a strike here troy aikman
yeah literally needed new pants because
he was so excited about the 20 yard
throw to Kupa the out route America
through before cup even broke a little
bit he was like a beast I was like whoa
chill out yeah he did that was it was a
phenomenal throw because he threw the
ball way before the guy was coming out
of the break and I think the reason he
freaks out is other quarterbacks have
done that but this is something we've
been waiting for Jared Goff for a long
time and this year if this is the Jared
Goff we're getting from now all right
hell yeah that's right and you know
what else said the Aikman say like you
gotta if you're listening to these games
you gotta listen to the cryptic language
sometimes like he made one point early
in the game like oh I would have loved
to play in this Sean McVeigh offense
it's pretty easy you know that's you
know that was him kind of saying like
it's easy to play quarterback in this
offense he didn't take a shot at but
golf made plays that were big-time in
this football game I think that's the
first thing I look at the Saints were
smart you know on defensive side of the
ball they played a little man early and
I think they realized okay we can't play
man-to-man on this great this this crowd
marshal Adam Moore I don't know what's
happened to him but he could not play on
an island on a consistent basis Marsh on
a lotta more for my money is not as good
this year as he was last year as a
rookie but I just thought overall Dennis
Allen played a did a good job of only
rushing for for the most part playing
zone coverage rallying to make tackles
not letting huge big plays an occasional
all we're gonna play man-to-man and
blitz here and there just to throw Sean
McVeigh off and all of that but I think
the biggest thing they did more than
anything is the Saints took away two
things from the Rams one was girly-girly
did not go off he had a good game but he
did not go off they were not gonna let
Gurley in the run game get started the
other thing is all the [ __ ] plays
they didn't happen you didn't see
screens to the wide receiver muster 40
yards he didn't see the speed sweep
turned the corner he didn't see Gurley
screens so how did they not let Gurley
get off when you say they didn't let
Gurley get off yet they played big
fronts up front Sheldon Rankin's played
one of his best games of the year the
kid David said people were tweeting us
about sheldon Rankin's the FTP you King
yeah he was kicking butt yes last night
was the best game he played he was
playing like a mini Aaron Donald
yesterday Wow yeah he was phenomenal he
was a top 11 yeah he's in that so
Sheldon ranked it so that they put
linebackers they put more people in the
box no they didn't they just you know
they're a good run defense they don't
they're number one in the NF actions and
and I said on Thursday because they have
a great pass on them right and I'm not
saying I agree I think that's you're
right they're left go like it this game
is call
sir I'm still not sold that they
wouldn't be able to run the ball with a
little more so because I thought if you
know when they went down 35 to 14 and
change it up but like girly was on those
first two drives was doing whenever he
wanted busted up the middle of yes times
yes he did have that gallop going right
but once they got their feet underneath
them a little bit had those guys in the
middle there there they're pretty good
for the Saints a jawline yeah we'll see
their jamario Davis is a phenomenal run
stopping linebacker okay you know
Anzalone he's more comes in in the
passing situations and does does things
like that
but you know the other guys Davison
Rankin's Okafor this rookie Stallworth
76 who comes in you know they just they
got the look they play tough and you're
not gonna just drive them out of there
in the run game and the Saints tackled
well for the day I'm not gonna sit here
and say they reinvented the wheel or did
anything totally crazy what are key [ __ ]
they just the zone defense was the
biggest thing at least they get to keep
their eyes on the screen game why does
on watch against the rim no boots it's
not it's not always easy you don't
always have the offense to sit there and
go well if they just start picking apart
our zone we have an offense to they can
start go down the field on them you have
to think about the full aspect of the
game as a head coach sometimes points
per game
yeah where do you think the Rams ranked
in the NFL surprising so they're not one
because that's the chin up points per
game allow oh yeah it's not great
because they've had games like the
Seahawks and the Vikings Packers where
do they rank I'm gonna say they're like
23rd in football I'm very surprised
their tenth their 10th ok our one slot
ahead of the Patriots the Panthers the
Chargers I thought they were gonna be in
the 20s it's early seasons it's early
season they let up nothing to Arizona
exactly and 13 to the Raiders those
skewed the Niners exact those skew the
points a little bit because I feel like
in the last I mean you look at that the
LA Rams and you pull up their schedule
and you go ok they let up 45 to the
Saints and 27 the Packers and 31 the
Seahawks and 31 the Vikings but now
they're their 10th yeah all right yeah
realize yeah that's that's pretty
amazing
all right so overall
though you leave this game and you feel
actually more confident about the Rams
and the Saints and yeah at I was like
why I died up because I think that the
this the Rams have a little more talent
on their football team not that I'm
saying they could win this game but I
just let the games in New Orleans I came
away going I just felt like I came away
going the game like man the Saints were
hanging on for their ass there for a
little while because you came into the
game go and the Saints are gonna beat ya
and the Saints could still beat them
there they have the right formula cuz of
that old wine and Sean Payton and Brees
and everything they bring to the the
table there but I think the next time
they play you know you can't depend on
them missing the fake field goal or the
field goal or golf throwing an
interception that game is a different
game it's very close this this would be
an amazing and SC championship game
amazing be through the roof can I hold
your crystal ball yeah so let's see it
ooh okay uh Steelers Ravens was the
other game I had you watch yeah and I
know you did some charger Seahawks too I
did John Harbaugh yeah the Ravens are
now four and five how does Ellen here
today well it's because the hot seat
that John Harbaugh is on is he right to
be on the hot seat do you believe that
John Harbaugh should be discussed being
fired right now no that's insane
I'd it's absolutely insane I mean if I
told you that in a three week span you
lost to the Saints on an extra point yep
you went to Carolina and got beat pretty
good yeah and then played at home and
lost to the Steelers and lost by a
touchdown
I mean Saints Panther Steelers and
they're going into the body right this
is their to me a lot like Jacksonville
where I would go I'm buying stock in the
Ravens going forward I'm not giving up
on them I mean I'm not gonna sit here
and go oh Cincinnati at the six spot
they really got this thing on lock know
what would make you think of the saint
cincinnati bengals got anything on lock
okay with that defense the way they've
been playing and of course their history
on the offensive side of the ball and aj
green maybe haven't get foot surgery I
also feel like people never pay
attention to injuries especially
their injuries on the offensive line
yeah they played this game on Sunday
without their two starting tackles I
know Ronnie Stanley and James Hearst did
not play in the game but that's but we
don't talk about why that's that's too
factual we'd rather just talk about
Harbaugh being on the hot seat
that's that's that's more fun to talk
about you don't let alone like Alex
Lewis just getting back in the lineup
not totally himself I think that's where
I'd start with that game okay let's
start there when a by big concern with
the Baltimore Ravens is if they can't
bully you upfront I don't know if they
can win football games and they've
played four teams in a row that go yeah
screw you you can't bully us Carolina
New Orleans Cleveland Pittsburgh right
right it's just I look at those and go
ma'am okay I really thought the Ravens
were gonna have the big year but this
seems like another 7 and 9 8 and 8 team
just not enough playmakers on the
defensive side of the ball like the
secondaries good and it's better but
there's just no seriously who's running
exactly right l saw I ain't got it like
exactly right none of them do so you get
to the edge where and who's the guy that
scares you on offense John Brown exactly
right and John Brown's is not as
explosive as I think the the world
thinks he is um we know your thoughts on
that Lex Collins yeah exactly right I
mean so there's nobody to make things
easier for that football team or make a
play when it does happen and yes when
you just go to Pittsburgh's offense
I mean Pittsburgh did two things they
said okay yep you're gigantic in the
middle we'll run off the edge a little
bit and if you watch the game you'll go
damn James Connors a lot of his carries
were off tackle or something along those
lines
yeah right it is exactly it and then the
other thing they did is okay you're
gonna play all these great zone coverage
as well okay cool great zone coverages
you know we can protect against your
group here so we'll protect and at some
point there will be a hole over the
middle and if you over the middle or
tight end over the middle and that's
what they did to them I mean with an
occasional outside throw here or there
but that was really the way the game
kind of fell for the Pittsburgh Steelers
that game was in Baltimore it was in
Baltimore so Baltimore goes to
Pittsburgh and beats the crap out of
them yeah and then Pittsburgh goes to
Baltimore and
beats them there yeah I might as well
been six years ago that last time they
plays in that while I know because
Pittsburgh's changed Pittsburgh how have
they changed well their defensive side
of the ball
hey guys like Cody sensible starting at
corners doing a really good job Joe
Hayden's back healthy the rookie
Tremayne which one is real this is a
Tremayne Jermaine Edmonds no torella
Terrell Edmonds but people are really
excited by Hilton they should be Hilton
supplier Mike Hilton they have a true
nickel guy who can run around the field
and not only cover the slot receivers
but he can make a difference in the pen
in the run game he's not afraid to
tackle there Sean Sean Davis is good but
the big thing is this
they're big [ __ ] in front are
starting to whoop ass to it inhaler
there are starting to what they whupped
the Baltimore result to it just chasing
down a flag off you today whooped the
Baltimore Ravens and Dupree had a nice
did a nice job going around you know
Elliman newer or whatever the other guy
that started for Ronnie Stanley yes um
and and really that's where the game was
won and then out of the fact that yeah
there's not enough of a creative system
in Baltimore in the past game and then
like you talked about there's no weapons
that scare you in the run game only the
pass game really and all those things
lead to a Pittsburgh advantage yeah and
like the one touchdown that Baltimore
had was really set up with that play of
that pass interference in the end zone
it was incredible it's like oh they need
a play oh there's Jesse James for 40
yards oh they need a play oh there's
juju on third and eight barely
stretching out and getting the first
down the huge one I thought was third
and five with four minutes left and they
hit a Antonio Brown over and that was
like the backbreaker yes they were able
to waste four to five minutes at right
end of the game to milk the clock right
it's all one clip of Orlando Brown
destroying tjy Orlando did good I mean
he doesn't he was certainly not the
weakness to that football game by any
stretch of the imagination but to me
Pittsburgh won the game yeah 22:13 right
and Big Ben died Big Ben runs out on a
play that's not even in a matter because
a defensive flag came out and I guess he
landed on the ball and all the wind
taken out of him but the announcer's
myself I didn't have anyone with me in
the office I'm going big banners dead
Big Ben is dead and instead Josh Dobbs
comes in and from his own endzone
throws a 20-yard piss missile to juju in
a cluster of three Ravens okay go ahead
now give him credit give him credit
whoo Josh Dobbs nope Mike Tomlin yep go
ahead it's the time because we ever you
do it I mean we all want to crap on Mike
Tomlin window oh it's it's a circus in
Pittsburgh they it's it's they're a mess
it's a bunch of renegades Mike Tomlin's
got no control it doesn't know how to
coach a football team and you know what
honey you know when that happened yeah
after the last time they played
Baltimore yeah you're right
they played Baltimore five weeks ago
scored 14 points Antonio Brown and Big
Ben are having a fight yeah levy ons
laughing from the strip club
juju doesn't even know what's going on
the defense is a mess and that was when
everyone went on TV and said Mike Tomlin
doesn't have it so again like beat
Atlanta beat the Bengals beat the Browns
beat the Ravens four in a row and no one
is out here going I'm sorry Mike Tom
come on I mean that's what's wrong with
our world right now
good says it's truly what's wrong with
our country like come on the guy is an
unbelievable people skills leader he
knows how to manage all these you know
for lack of a better phrase crazy
personalities and he's got he's got a
diva quarterback he's got a running back
that wants to be paid is worth he's got
a court receiver who's only worried
about Instagram
he's got juju who's young and just
having fun and doesn't he's obsessed
with Instagram right and they're all
super famous right doesn't mean it's not
like this is the easiest job in the
world and then here they are back in the
cream of the crop of the AFC that you
haven't you ever you have Hall of Fame
quarterbacks that call you out in the
media all the time they use a clay for
that franchise Barry Brad jealous right
so when you play you coach an
organization where people say things
like that's not the Steeler way
which is like a [ __ ] statement it
doesn't even mean anything yeah it's
like Giants fans last three years that's
not the way of a New York chime well
what is the way of a New York shine
[ __ ] flame it out in the third week
for me we just marry so you want to give
credit to my Tom we gather we got to we
got to give it I mean if we're gonna
self Scout we got a self Scout everybody
and people were too critical of him and
plays like that to dot like da thought
that endears you to the locker room
right there which place the Dobbs Oh
coach gives the green light therefore
the OC to call a play with this backup
quarterback backed up in his own end
zone in a huge situation to change the
field position for the football game
that was that was enormous have you ever
been brought in in a one play situation
as a backup
oh no not a one play her brother has I
remember when he had to come in against
Kansas City yeah you're right that's
gotta be crazy that's crazy coming in
the first time I ever got in a game like
that in general was against Nick Saban
and the Miami Dolphins I was like damn I
gotta throw in here with Zach Thomas and
Jason Taylor and I'm cold as hell and
haven't done anything I threw it out
route complete 20 yards 20 yards yeah
something like that now you're like Josh
Dobbs
yeah I thought Big Ben died though okay
yes what advice on what what's it like
yeah we should I'm so unethical he's
such a diva and with those kind of plays
you know my pet peeve of those like if
we have to go to commercial break cause
you're dying on the field and then
you're in one play later yeah you gotta
sit out you you wasted all our time
because the wind knocked got knocked out
of you come on man that's crazy
Le'Veon Bell apparently tweeted today
farewell Miami hmm and what I really
liked is instead of f ar e wel L he went
fa ir like you're going to stay fair
farewell Miami which people are reading
into it and going whoa
maybe levee ons coming back to the
Steelers this week yeah what advice
would you have for Le'Veon Bell come
back let's go just be a good soldier get
your six weeks in right get a full year
on your contract your money get yourself
in shape and
do you think he's in shape right now yes
I do think he's in shape yeah I just
don't know what shape yeah well he's not
running back shape for the NFL I know
that that that I can tell you but come
back be a good soldier
and be humble he'll have a discussion
with his own line and those guys well
this is my question
yeah and Josh we're talking about this
earlier does Tomlin go to Le'Veon and is
it like when we watch on Hard Knocks and
a rookie gets in front of the team and
he's got a singing stuff not singing but
does he go what do you want to say to
the team did is he given that right and
is that a right
that's a great question and he will be
given that right he's a whole walk in
and he'll probably meet with Tomlin
right a Wednesday morning when they know
the whole team's gonna be there I would
imagine somebody like Le'Veon Bell or
Mike Tomlin is gonna go hey I think you
should say something just say something
you know you think levy I would go to
Tom and say I'd want to say something I
do
Azzam just the times I bet I am a levy
on Belle fan as a person you know that
being around him he is a he's got a
great way about him friendly guy fun and
loving nice nice nice 'no sin his eyes
it shines through you're all about the
ayah that shines through no Simms if he
there have been a few people where he's
come to me to go left go there's
something in his eye and I go and I go
you know what about six months this
guy's gonna do something and Simms is
gonna be right I have that thing to I
can call it out yeah yeah and there's
been a few people in this office he'll
have that he'll have that opportunity
what would you say to the team if you
were loved you know if I'm about your
the synopsis of your speech I love
football
it was killing me not to be here and I
wanted to be here to be a good teammate
do you apologize you you apologize for
the fact that you weren't here but you
you also make it clear that this is what
I felt was right for me as my business
and the situation I was in here so if he
stood up and said I'm sorry that I let
you guys down yeah it killed me not to
be here right running back position we
get screwed and I thought I needed to
take a stand and honestly
know that you guys I appreciate you not
talking about my money it was a personal
situation
I left you down James you were
incredible yeah
you killed it right and I'm happy to be
in the back field with you yeah and I
want to go win a [ __ ] Super Bowl yeah
you think they'd be excited I do all
right and that's all it would take it's
all it's all it's gonna take not the
next day so what is it gonna come up to
in the locker room be like yo man I'm
still a little bit pissed off that's all
it's gonna take
well it's gonna take everything you
understand it so are they where some of
the players in the locker room bitter at
first yeah because they want to win the
Super Bowl so but they're being bitter
for their own personal benefit they're
they get what's going on
if levy on bail we know he won't be
ready right away yeah but if he's up to
game speed by the playoffs
can you play James Connor and levy on
together and what would that offense be
like with juju Antonio Brown the
emerging Vance McDonald yeah I mean no
they can definitely play together the
greatness that those two have is they
have a similar skill set so the offense
doesn't have to change but then they
could throw both of them out there on
the field and you could do oh you have
one linebacker that come over running
back right you have to you have to
exactly or oh you have a Landon Roberts
oh that's great Dante you're stuck on
James Connor yeah well that's what I
mean that's the things they'll be able
to do you put both them in the backfield
oh here's a fake to James Caan or here
comes love you on Belle the other way
they're gonna be able to play action run
write you sick [ __ ] cut they'll be able
to do if they're smart they'd be able to
do some Cam Newton North Turner Carolina
Panther stuff you know there goes
Le'Veon Bell the speed sweep up we
didn't give it to them we gave it to
James Conner and the guards pulling
around that way out ten yards up yours
for following levy oh wow I mean those
are the things that I would do and it
takes those kind of rosters to beat the
Patriots it does yes you people
physically better than that right
and multiple yeah so you think do you
believe that by the playoffs yes this
will be a Steelers offense yes and your
prediction of Steelers Saints the only
thing out that out of this yet no
they're definitely more in than my
Packers yeah yeah I mean yeah I'm not
ready to anoint them better than the
Chiefs or the Patriots at this point no
but they're still gonna be dangerous you
pleasantly surprised me and you were
able to watch char
see all right which side of the ball did
you watch i watch both Wow laughter all
right so I watched that game very
intently I had a good amount of bleacher
bucks on the Seahawks which I
immediately regretted like as soon as I
turn the game on it didn't help that I'm
watching the game and like in the second
quarter the reason I bet on them Chris
Carson goes out Chris Carson was having
success he was he was running on the
Chargers the Philip Rivers offense with
that multitude of weapons a few things I
want to say yeah that Mike Williams was
a hundred percent out on that thirty
yard touchdown play his foot was on the
line like I could not believe that your
bleacher bucks talking he was he not out
I I would say yes he was out I would but
I her say they would have probably
scored anyway I'm saying I don't know if
we can conclusively sit there and say he
was out I don't I saw white and I saw
his foot on it Melvin Gordon is a
monster yeah it was a guy like the
Seahawks didn't even know what they were
getting themselves into yeah and Austin
Eckler is such a good change of pace
back for him because he's a he's a half
a step faster than Gordon in the hole
and he's just slippery enough to break
the tackles Keenan Allen had his best
game of the year Keenan Allen made so
many guys miss just on running Ralph in
front of amazing at that he really is
and then on the Seahawks offense I just
[ __ ] hated their offense like for
three quarters of that game ya know they
they didn't really get to stay patient
with their run game once they got behind
so you didn't get to see that and yeah
that that to me would be that really
these teams you know in a nutshell are
mirror images of each other really
they're the same team except that the
schematics in the pass game for the
Chargers are greater than the schematics
of that what the Seahawks have the
Seahawks a little bit like you know hey
they I like their run game and some of
the things are doing but when it comes
to passing it's a little bit like Aaron
Rodgers it's just man Russell drop back
and throw missiles or run around until
somebody gets open the problem is
between those two teams is that when
Russell drops back that's when Ingram
starts getting the sacks
that's when Rachelle is in the backfield
and I'm seeing Russell Wilson with
like a pool of blood right down his
elbow right where Phillip Rivers goes oh
you mean I can go 5 wide as I have all
of those horses all those horses and I
think that and their offensive lines a
lot better that's where they have a
bouncy at center they've been building
this offensive line for two to three
years but everyone's been hurt no they I
think that was the difference in the
game is right there when I just watched
you know when you watch I just go the
the Seahawks were in a predicament as
far as defending their team they could
not get pressure with four people on
Phillip Rivers they couldn't get no host
to him it was a stone wall session by
the Chargers old line and pass
protection then it became oh well maybe
we'll rush five or six but the problem
was then damn you can't cover everybody
else down the field so that became a
huge issue for the game yeah Melvin
Melvin Gordon when you watch the
Chargers offense it's like they like to
spread you out and you're like I think
we're figuring out their past offense
and then Melvin Gordon is like a
Clydesdale for 35 yards and you're out
of luck you had a lot but Russell Wilson
I feel like he was running for his life
for most of things yeah well he was
absolutely the last quarter I mean
that's all it was it was just him making
plays you know that you know the
Chargers old line is real
the Chargers old line is one of those
old lines that you know I don't know
which one I could say they're better at
zone or pulling guard blocking like that
one's own or man blocking they do both
really well and I think that's a another
huge thing for them but the other big
thing I thought in the football game
was the Seahawks or the kings of the
field position game and the Seahawks
with Dixon yes and they backed up
Chargers a few times but the Chargers
changed the field position it is to not
give Russell Wilson and that offense the
chance to throw one big play for a
touchdown because that's kind of both of
these teams are big play teams it's not
about like sustained rise for either one
it's like it's a gain of 50 and we're
inside that 15 and let's see if we can
make a play again to score a touchdown
that's kind of the way they play and I
thought that was a huge thing you know
the Chargers D the Chargers D you like
to your point yeah second third quarter
right to 226 left in the third quarter
yeah Michael Dixon punts it out and by
itself it bounces
on the five which is incredible right
second and ten Melvin Gordon 20 yard run
yeah they're out of it completely
different it's the Chargers have like
four or five guys that can flip field
position just by touching the ball no
Mike Williams is good out jump you Kenan
Allen's gonna cut you up right Tyrell
Williams can outrun you Travis Benjamin
can outrun you and Melvin Gordon can
outrun you jump over you run through you
exactly right they have so many guys
that instantly change the field and
that's why they're a Super Bowl
contender that's why they are they're a
Super Bowl contender because of that and
you know the thing they're doing on
defense you know the only thing I'll say
about the the Chargers and we've been
saying this for a little bit for a few
years and I know Joey Bosa will be back
and he's their best defensive player
that would be amazing when he does get
back but I do question whether they have
enough big people still that'll be so
bad I do you know I worry about them in
a game like against the Patriots where I
worry about them where you know they
want to only play one linebacker they
want to play three safeties in one
linebacker that's how the Chargers gonna
play and their three safeties are
Phillips Derwin James and a you know
died a yes 30:37 right and I love that
you know how I like the three safety
they're great and it really makes things
like in the past I'd like to hear as a
linebacker all together and just find
for safeties but Derwin James is bigger
than most lines well he is in some cases
but those linebackers come in handy like
three or four games a year when you have
to play a sledgehammer team if you have
to pie the Saints and they're running at
you and all of a sudden you go damn and
repeats get into our second level and I
think he swallowed our third safety and
he's not here anymore
that's the thing I would worry about
with them more than anything luge it was
phenomenal Liege it sorry he was what it
was his best game back so far but I
think that just they just need one other
big guy there that's the only thing that
scares me
as as a whole for their goose Carson
didn't get hurt
yes would that have been a different
game because you talked about the
sledgehammer I felt like they lost their
sledge I liked Mike Davis but he's not
Chris Carter no he's not Chris Carson is
one of the best after contact he's
another guy that you don't like latavius
Murray he is they're just their Greek
gods where they're just the chiseled and
cut out of granite um yeah I do think it
gives them the confidence maybe to be a
hair more
our patient with it when they have him
back there that roughing the passer by
the way we asked them two minutes left
with such [ __ ] yeah on Russell
Wilson yeah there was there is a number
I thought of [ __ ] cause there's the
other thing too that people have to
realize in the NFL that's a rule that's
being misconstrued when people are
watching oh the DB he has to turn and
play the ball no he doesn't
we have face guarding is on a roll
facing guard face guarding is legal in
the NFL now if he hits the guy of course
that's passed interference but if he has
his hand in front of the receivers face
and is not looking to play the ball
there it is legal in the NFL I think
that gets overlooked a lot of times and
I feel like it's called that time so the
referee forgets it right I would say
that just looking at how I feel like
most offensive back coaches in the NFL
right now are not even trying to get
guys to try and intercept the ball yes
it's more of attacked the hands yes like
whenever I watch NFL games right now
it's attacked the hands it's almost let
them catch it and then punch that right
like that's what it feels like when I
watch them it is it's a new way I don't
get it I don't like it and I guess I
speak to Tony Dungy burn I think the
turn is when you lose a guy you lose a
guy you lose sight of the ball and now
you're just guessing you're trying to
play his eyes and his hands from when
he's about to catch it yeah if I was
wide receiver I'd be running and I just
keep flaring my or you slow your eyes or
you put your hands up for a half a
second the guy rakes them inning the
ball is not there I mean those are
tricks that that receivers really will
do but that charger defense is fast I
thought for the most part other than
those last two drives did a very good
job of keeping Russell Wilson in the
pocket
there was definitely a conscious effort
there not to go crazy
our main new chanaan Owoh su out of USC
he popped a bunch of times on film and
the pick-6 was really the biggest play
of the game he just he got fooled by a
desmond king desmond king is its cover
three press bail and he's just going out
there to get underneath anything on the
outside route he kind of rode the slot
guy just for a second to where I think
Russell goes oh he's going with the slot
guy and then he went out and the ball
just hit him right in the face Esmond
King is a guy that will make one big
mistake every game but I can also win
you the kick and make some big plays he
plays the game like he's a returner yeah
what she is yeah I'm gonna take this one
in the house right yeah he left the game
feel
confident about both more confident the
charge yes more confident about the
Chargers but yeah I'm not giving up on
the Seahawks either you know the
Seahawks are that team that I look like
I look at in the NFC right now and the
NFC is damn good I mean gosh damn it
it's also a jumbled mess it is a jumbled
mess and the South is all over the place
in the East ain't that great I just look
at you guys in Philadelphia is the only
two teams in the outside and goals are
Seahawks yes only two teams on the
outside looking and there were two teams
with the experience that they might be
able to put it together you might be
able to write um let me just get to a
few of my left code Nuggets yeah
Washington went from two-game lead in
the NFC East to I think they're done I
think Trent Williams is expected to miss
a month Shaun LaValle Brandon Scherff
are out for the year and uh Morgan Moses
go Paul Richardson oh yeah but I'm Bette
that game and I'm going so the advantage
that I bet on was this great offensive
line that's pushed people for a month
and they're all gonna be out by the
middle of the second quarter
okay it's like a repeat of last year and
then I'm sitting there like I'm watching
that game heavy cuz it was the one bet
that I was like I don't know about this
one of I should have made it did you
make it a lock yes he did they had ten
penalties for a hundred and forty seven
yards dude I'm telling you if I was a
Washington fan and I'm watching that
game every big Adrian Peterson run every
big Alex Smith pass brought back by
penalty yeah every time they stopped the
Falcons penalty on third down
10 for 147 I don't know if the Patriots
have had 10 for 147 all year I don't
know the penalties were so bad that I'm
by myself a bleacher pork on May the
rest of us that got paid that's when you
know your bets I just felt like when I
was looking over it was always holding
on the old line or anything like that
was it or after a monster place yeah
plays like that illegal hands to illegal
hands all that stuff the other thing I'm
going home and they're not gonna be able
to run on Washington and I wrote down on
my notes left ko you idiot Tevin Coleman
I laugh all they do is run them to the
outside guess where they're not running
it right into the Alabama big boys Tevin
Coleman averaged six point eight yards
per
you killed me yeah Jets dolphins yeah
nine of Miami's eleven drives ended in
punts Josh and they won that game that
game is ugly have there been any team
that has pulled more wins out of their
ass than the Miami Dolphins a Tennessee
seven our the Jets gained the first time
they were not the better team in the
field a Jets game this time they had two
drives that didn't end in punts Oakland
was they were down like double digits
and that one Chicago was the gate was
the pulling the rabbit out of there game
of the year they have five wins right
now it's incredible incredible and
there's one of their best safeties that
they paid a lot of money to Rashad Jones
but he pulled himself out of the game
because he didn't want to pull a tune
with Minka Fitzpatrick she's and they
win the game Wow
yeah because we're shot blues some
coverages against the Texans the week
before so of course he had a platoon I
mean also thing also why is Frank Gore
getting like double the carries of
Kenyan jury I don't know how they trust
him I don't know it's as a can you drink
fantasy owner I just want to say after
you watched them score against the
Texans right how was Kenyan Drake now
playing every game at every snap I don't
know I thought we would have learned
this by now
the Dolphins though at the very least
the one thing I'm known is the last two
years okay they beat the teams you're
supposed to be
they might not never beat anybody else
but they beat the team's you go who it's
close matchup beer they always seem to
win that football all I know is I had
them one in seven games in in Atlantic
City and I'm two games away from cashing
that ticket mm-hmm the other one that
I'm super excited about cashing the
Buffalo Bills under five wins boy is
that looking good
lions Vikings Matt Stafford was sacked
ten times yeah and his team scored nine
points yeah that's crazy crazy Everson
Griffin a sack and a half Tom Johnson
two and a half sacks and I struggled
before the year am I gonna pick Yannick
and gawk way am I gonna pick Tennille
hunter I picked you on to concoct way to
Neal hunter three and a half sacks you
were a year too early now he's leading
the NFL
sacks and had a touchdown and on an
awful decision by Matt Stafford ruff
Matt Stafford game brah but Taylor
Decker was pulled out with an injury in
that one but that was the price of
surprising I mean the the pressure was
great
but I also it looked like just on TV the
Lions were moving the ball the entire
first half moved it but just could never
I think play to get open or he every
time the red zone yeah sack right settle
for a field goal yeah I'm shocked
because the line offensive line has been
a positive for that team
Lions and Seahawks I think we're my -
what the hell happened yeah
and Washington but injuries Bucs
Panthers the one thing that I wrote down
this game and I'm obviously I have tons
of notes about this game and how it was
a complete [ __ ] show and McCaffrey's
amazing and then what exactly how I
that's the reason I didn't bet a lot of
money on that game is here come the buck
right but the one thing I wrote down is
it's time to talk about Dante Jackson
mm-hmm he had an interception at a
crucial time in that game you loved him
coming out of LSU Rachel I think that
you'll study him it may be a little bit
more but Curtis Samuel popped and Dante
Jackson pot yeah they've got athletes
yeah that's right yeah the fact the
Dante Jackson factor for their defense
has allowed them to play some spotty
man-to-man for the first time in a while
where they can trust two guys and
Bradbury and him and situations where
they mostly want to play zone but they
can go we you know it's third and seven
we're gonna change it up here and let
them lock people down and Dante
Jackson's he's like glue he he was he
was arguably he was in the conversation
for best pure man-to-man cover corner in
the draft he was in that combo with
Denzel gyre Alexander and Mike Hughes
for my money Dante Jackson tied for the
league lead in the NFL with four
interceptions yeah the only guy that we
haven't seen that you really liked his
DJ charkh no I know
yeah he's not a few catches here and
there for Jacksonville but not quite to
the deep explosive type yet alright
let's let's get to just a social
question this is a social thing this is
from Jo that sent us to us Jo Sperry Jay
apparently on reddit they started a new
stat and I love it and it's called the
Dawson deshaun Watson and Patrick
mahomes pulled off the stat this year
it's when you throw more touchdowns than
incompletions and it's named after Len
Dawson because I believe he used to do
it a lot I love that stat I'd like to
bring it into our podcast sure that if
someone does the Dawson
it's one of the best things you but
number two only we'll bring it in only
if you can tell me what number Len
Dawson was when he played for the Kansas
State cheese if not we don't bring it in
[Music]
give me one clue is it single digit or
double it's double digit okay and then
and an all-time great has worn this
number and it's not 12 I'll tell you
that okay okay I think that it is 18 19
17 16 16 well Len Dawson was on the
Chiefs Chiefs and then did Joe Montana
where 16 when he went to the Chiefs no
he wore 19 and he went to the chief
that's why so he changed it to 19
because of Len Dawson I think so what I
know about Len Dawson because I
obviously don't know too much or the
football his story no Len Dawson and one
of those quarterbacks in the late 60s
early 70s that was ahead of his time
they were truly throwing I mean he I if
I remember correctly maybe we have to
pull out is he the way I was
matriculated in the ball game exactly
right I mean I used to smoke cigarettes
in the locker room they got pictures of
them doing that you know it's halftime
right I know that cigarettes kill you
and if I smoke you're dumb right but I'm
still if I see people smoking I think
they're cool I'm here know and I can
shoot it right like I'm gonna teach when
I have children me like you see that guy
he's stupid but like in my heart I'm
gonna be like look at him blowing out
that is so cool it looks cool yeah but
like Len Dawson drinking a beer at
halftime and smoking a cigarette of the
Super Bowl you're like what I know he
had some years I want to see me hit a
few years there where it was like 32 34
touchdown passes which come on back in
those days are you looking it up right
now are you pulling no no no no but when
you when you back in those days that was
like throwing 455
touchdown passes I mean damn you know
what Len Dawson's nickname was what was
it Lenny the cool that's smoking those
cool smokes man he's born is born in
Alliance Ohio with the same birthday of
three of my exes oh here you go just
real quick it's 62 he had 29 touchdowns
26 touchdown passes 30 touchdown passes
21 touchdown passes 26 24 in that day
and age that's pretty special that's
Alec Smith's career yeah we're gonna end
on a socially conscious note okay if
you're listening to this it's Tuesday I
really hope you guys are voting in the
midterms that's right if if they're
providing any information read it learn
about it I have a packet at home that
I'm gonna read tonight about all of the
different votes I can do and all the
different candidates and kind of
learning all that stuff but I'm gonna be
voting tomorrow yeah I hope you're
voting tomorrow I I'm gonna try I don't
know I got work well your we're gonna
leave here and you're gonna do that yeah
I hopefully will get out of here at a
good time I hope so too
yes all right there you can read some
notes on how you can beat me in bet so
ever again I give me my ball how dare
thy all right force him he's a hell me
bedrick would say and the lef koe and
says haves more Luck's in your pets than
me and I hope the Cowboys win tonight
see you guys
[Music]